[Musique]
échoué pour les quelques-uns d'entre
vous qui sont pas encore familiers avec
l'organisation interne des services
spéciaux notamment sur l'esprit sur
français le service de renseignement de
sécurité celui qui est chargé du recueil
du renseignement et de la mise en oeuvre
des mesures actives à l'extérieur du
territoire national en matière de contre
criminalité de contre-espionnage de
contre prolifération et de contre
terrorisme alors tout ça c'est des
activités tout à fait ludique qui se
déroule à l'étranger donc évidemment
dans l'illégalité la plus absolue et
dans le plus grand secret et ça donne du
monde une vision un peu spécialisés
[Musique]
monsieur chou et bonjour je vous
interview aujourd'hui pour un site
internet qui s'appelle think ur view
c'est un site internet qui donne
l'opportunité à des personnes qui sont
passées entendu de s'exprimer on
voudrait avoir votre point de vue sur la
syrie la fin de
votre qualité d' expertise de terrain
sur l'actualité
bien alors je cherche pas spécialement
être être entendu je le suis je pour
suffisamment
d'articles de conférences
considérés comme peu orthodoxes sur la
série parce que je suis pas dans le
mainstream ce qu'il veut pas dire pour
autant que je suis un soutien du régime
en place que je connais bien puisque mes
premiers voyages en série de 1966 et
messieurs rendu régulièrement pendant
quarante ans que j'ai parfaitement
conscience que le régime syrien est un
régime autoritaire brutale et assez peu
démocratique
simple la simple question que je me pose
laquelle je cherche dispense cette
savoir si l'opposition et la rébellion
actuelle sont réellement porteur de
valeurs démocratiques est capable de
mettre en place un système politique
comparable au nôtre au moins en matière
de liberté de droits de l'homme et pour
l'instant je ne vois pas de signes de de
cette ouverture dans la rébellion
syrienne
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
le financement et l'armement de la
rébellion syrienne alors sur le
financement de la rébellion syrienne
je crois que tout le monde sait c'est
aujourd'hui à peu près ce qu'il en est
puisque les financiers eux mêmes ne se
sont pas cachés
de ce qu'il faisait le l'émirat du qatar
et l'arabie saoudite ont clairement
revendiquée assistées financièrement
[Musique]
et militairement la rébellion le les
services
spéciaux c'est bien
reconnaît avoir été à l'origine de la
création des jardins sera le front de la
victoire qui se revendique lui-même de
deux de l'organisation al qaïda même si
cette organisation est devenue assez la
naissance mais je m'appelle l'eau sera
donc créée par les séoudiens le
revendique clairement son appartenance à
la mouvance
violente il serait remise du holland
internationale elle a d'ailleurs été
classé sur la liste des mouvements
terroristes par l'administration
américaine qui a entrepris récemment un
certain nombre de mesures
contre contre se montre cette
organisation qui reste quand même la
principale organisation de l'opposition
armée au régime actuel qu'est ce que
vous pouvez me dire de la position de la
france sur le conflit fait rien la
position de la france j'ai un peu de mal
de mal à la suivre dans la mesure où on
l'a vu tout récemment à quinze jours
d'intervalle le président de la
république s'est proposé dans un premier
temps d'armer la rébellion syrienne même
si
même si la communauté internationale s'y
opposer pour ensuite les quinze jours
plus tard dire qu'il n'allait pas un art
mais cette rébellion parce qu'il n'avait
aucune garantie de savoir où aller les
armes c'est une politique et pelo
voyante dont je vois bien que
elle consiste évidemment
fondamentalement à soutenir soutenir la
révolte et la rébellion syrienne mais
qui n'a pas l'air de trop bien savoir à
qui s'adresser pour que ce soutien soit
efficace et débouche sur des réformes
démocratiques aux libertés
qu'elle porte de sortie pour ce conflit
pour l'instant j'en vois pas les les ce
conflit dure depuis deux ans qui
témoigne du fait que le pouvoir en place
dispose quand même
d'un soutien populaire parce qu'aucune
dictature
ne disposent d'aucun soutien populaire
ne peut tenir deux ans face à face à une
rébellion armée
les deux ans de deux ans de guerre
civile puisque c'est bien une guerre
civile qu'il s'agit ont occasionné de
telles destructions à la fois de
l'appareil économique de l'appareil
d'état veut les choses ne seront plus
jamais comme avant que ce pouvoir le
pouvoir en place a perdu beaucoup de sa
légitimité et sa capacité
sa capacité de commandement
d'administration de gouvernance que pour
l'instant les seules portes sortie
convois sont soit le la prolongation sur
le long terme d'une guerre civile à la
libanaise qui devaient s'affronter les
communautés ethniques et religieuses
soit une partition du pays en entités
ethniques et religieuses différentes
entre les alaouites druzes les
ismaéliens les chrétiens et les
musulmans sunnites et puis les kurdes
aussi commencent à manifester comme en
irak des volonté d'autonomie voire
d'indépendance
la russie la chine la russie
la russie je crois que la première
motivation de la russie dans son soutien
non pas à la syrie mais à l'ordre établi
à lormes internationales établies vient
du fait que les français les anglais ont
très largement outrepassé le mandat
qu'ils avaient reçu de l'organisation
des nations unies en libye où on a les
français les anglais avait comme mandat
de protéger des populations civiles
d'une répression haut parleurs à ma part
armes lourdes du gouvernement en place
mais qu'ils ont très largement
outrepassé son mandat en armant la
rébellion en la reconnaissant
diplomatiquement en prenant les palais
tout l'appareil d'état libyen et in fine
et en faisant léger le dirigeant libyen
avec l'aide de systèmes de détection ont
permis de localiser puis de le livrer au
lynchage de la foule devant les
télévisions alors les ni les russes ni
les chinois n'ont envie que l'onu se
transforme en une machine à donner les
bons et des mauvais points de
gouvernance et permettent à des
coalitions occidentales
de de se débarrasser militairement des
régimes qui leur plaisent pas ça a été
je pense nous la première raison pour
laquelle la chine et la russie freine
des quatre pattes et opposent leur veto
un certain de décision
d'intervention internationale aux séries
pour la russie en a d'autres et la
protection des minorités d'un corps
d'homme je ne crois pas beaucoup
au fait que la russie serait motivée
dans les ventes d'armes qu'elle a fait
la syrie sur la série n'a jamais payé
les armes fournies ni par des
considérations stratégie de cornaux
profonde qui en méditerranée qui est une
merveille n'a pas beaucoup de sens la
position des états unis est longue la
position nette annuelle m'est apparu
fructueux
et de vos cours des deux trois dernières
années et il clair qu'au départ les
états unis ont commencé comme la france
et la grande-bretagne à soutenir la
rébellion syrienne et avouez le le
régime syrien gémonies appelé à son
renversement et puis en s'apercevant
maintenant que
l'opposition politique syrienne est
extrêmement instable marginalisés et n'a
aucune autorité sur l'appareil militaire
en s'apercevant que l' armée syrienne
libre et totalement neutralisé par le
parti islamiste tueur pour laisser la
place uniquement au mouvement islamique
armé se revendiquant du djihadisme les
américains commencent à se poser des
questions sur leur engagement et et même
à entreprendre un certain nombre
d'actions militaires contre ces
mouvements djihadistes après vers la
jordanie israël et c'est donc je ne sais
pas très bien où l'administration obama
au cours de son second mandat il est
clair que à la fin du premier mandat
d'obama l'administration américaine a
souhaité avec hillary clinton comme
département d'état a soutenu la
rébellion syrienne ça me semble beaucoup
moins évident aujourd'hui et je pense
que il faut essayer de discerner dans
les semaines ou dans les mois qui
viennent quelles seront les options de à
la fois du département d'état et du
département pentagone
vis-à-vis de la rébellion série est-ce
que vous pouvez nous bien un petit mot
sur la fermera le fermera est une
affaire de
maintien de l'ordre de et de politique
intérieure sur lequel je suis pas
réellement compétent que parler moi je
considère que mes erreurs et est
beaucoup plus un cas psychiatrique que
cat terrorisme international je vois pas
de différence fondamentale entre eux
l'attitude de mes rôles la dérive de
meira et celle d'un monsieur comme
anders breivik en norvège ou d'un team
audi mal vu aux etats unis le type fait
l'attentât d'oklahoma city je pense que
c'est un cas psychiatrique c'est comme
un derby que c'est un monsieur qui a eu
besoin de rationaliser ses délires ses
délires de violence ces délires de
révolte et de rébellion et les à
rationaliser en puisant dans son fonds
culturel personnel qui est celui des des
flamboyants ce2 de la révolte et à 10
commandeur brésil lui peut puiser dans
le vieux fond nazis le bleu fondaci
européen mais quand des gens comme
claude guéant ou bernard squarcini parle
à propos de meira
loup solitaire je crois qu'ils ont
parfaitement raison n'en déplaise à
certain nombre
d'experts autoproclamés dans la totale
et ils ont parfaitement raison c'est pas
parce que mes reins a reçu le soutien de
sa famille
l'etna copain et lui a prêté à scooter
volé qu'il a déclenché l'enthousiasmé
d'une centaine d'abrutis sur facebook
que ça fait de lui un membre à part
entière d'une internationale 10 à 10 du
holland qui aurait un projet politique
et des projets spécifiques c'est un type
qui a agi seul il a fait deux séjours je
crois assez court en afghanistan dont il
a été expulsé une première fois pour
pour défaut de passeport et dont il a dû
partir une deuxième fois pour des
raisons de santé il y a sûrement
rencontrer des extrémistes religieux
mais vu la densité d'extrémistes
religieux en avait dix ans c'est pas
étonnant qu'il en ait rencontré cela dit
cette façon les instructions qu'il a agi
pour se livrer à des actes de violences
en france
keane qui ne sert aucune course le
massacre de boston pour le massacre de
boston où on est on est là dans la même
configuration à mon sens enfin sous
réserve d'éléments à fournir maintenant
par l'enquêté on est rarement c'est
suffisamment où il est possible que en
ce qui concerne mes reins sa dangerosité
était sous-évalué par les services de
la sécurité intérieure c'est possible
que pour les deux jeunes gens de boston
ce soit la même chose mais sauf un
sont fait avoir des éléments nouveaux
qui les relierait là aussi à une
internationale
révolutionnaire djihadistes je pense
qu'on est là aussi dans des parcours
individuels de de révolte de rébellion
duel de gens mal intégrés
et qui rationalisent leurs besoins de
violences par leur attachement à une
certaine forme de religion mais qui ont
agi de façon à ces individus un dernier
petit mot sur l'esprit critique des
médias qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire
sur leurs lectures leur façon de
présenter l'information
aussi vous je suppose que vous voulez
parler des médias français
opérant oui puzzle pour les médias
américains - problème c'est une espèce
de grande ignorance du reste du monde
et
une espèce d'arrogance qui fait que pour
eux l'amérique est au centre de tout et
quand quand un pétard dans une poubelle
quelques plans c'est forcément que les
américains davis n'est pas toujours
lorsqu'ils concernent
la france en particulier
ce que je constate beaucoup en france et
que nos médias en particulier nos nos
journaux mais aussi nos mots nos médias
audiovisuels font beaucoup de leçons de
morale d'éditoriaux de commentaires et
assez peu d'informations et en tout cas
il n'y aura beaucoup l'histoire ligne
ont beaucoup les contextes et contextes
sociaux les contextes culturels et eux
vécu l'une une espèce de forme de pensée
unique et de bien pensants ce qu'ils
essayent de conforter chaque jour en
tirant tous dans la même direction comme
un banc de poissons mais évoluent tous
dans la même direction sans trop savoir
laquelle d'ailleurs parce qu'on sait
jamais quel est le pilote du banc de
poissons là la crédibilité de nos
politiques avec les conflits libyen
syrien égyptien
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je crois
que l'opinion publique se trompent pas
trop le l'a trouvée ne faut jamais se
moquer de l'opinion publique même si
elle est basique elle voit quand même
bien les choses et on voit bien que
points
l'opinion publique jugement ou a du mal
à comprendre les options pour les
options politiques de nos différends je
fais pas de discrimination puisqu'il se
sont tous s'enferrer dans les dents les
mêmes problématiques ce que je constate
en revanche c'est que sur tous nos
options politiques font que la politique
française n'est plus crédible nulle part
dans la mesure où
on peut le jeu qu'on a adoré
on combat la mort des gens qui ont
invité deux ans avant
un soin soit défilé défilé du 14 juillet
la place d'honneur soit à monter leur
tente dans les jardins manade d'un grand
hôtel parisien pour ensuite appeler m là
l'heure est au bout d'une pique alors
non non partenaires d'autres
méditerranée s'y retrouve pas trop mais
je crois que l'opinion publique
française non plus il retrouve pas trop
et effectivement quand elle voit un
président un public
changé d'opinion est d'avis sur le
soutien à donner à la rébellion syrienne
en quinze jours lors qui s'est rien
produit de
spectaculaire dans cet espace de 15
jours nos concitoyens ont sans vie du
mal à suivre un peu les méandres de
notre politique extérieure
un dernier mot un conseil pour les
jeunesse une jeunesse qui pourrait vous
regardé par internet qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez leur dire par rapport à leur
esprit critique comment endurcir travail
et affûter leur esprit critique
j'ai eu un conseil alors apprenez
l'histoire parce que ce qui dope
explique pas tout mais ceux qui la
connaissent pas sont condamnés l'abeille
apprenez l'histoire et
il n'y a pas de pensée magique il n'y a
pas de fous
2 les gens qui font quelque chose c'est
que ils ont besoin de le faire par
rapport leur passé culturel leur passé
historique les violences qu'ils ont
subies ce qu'ils ont fait subir à
d'autres et si on connaît pas tout se
passait on peut pas comprendre le
présent
[Musique]